hey guys quick question
we got a guy down here that's trying to
steal a jet ski
he's on the he's on the jet ski in the
river is there any way you can take a
couple of us down there to him sure sure
okay
you want wanna take the boat you take it
come back
he's willing to let us use the boat
i know you got lots of boating
experience
come over here
right
you don't know how to swim
[Music]
do you have any weapons on you
take this line
any weapons guns knives anything
[Music]
thank you you're welcome i'm sergeant
turner by the way i gave him a card okay
i'm sergeant turner thank you very much
absolutely great
[Music]
let me go give this to these guys